c'est un secteur qui a souvent du mal à
recruter de jeunes apprentis notre série
avoir 20 ans et consacré aujourd'hui un
jeune boulanger il s'appelle joseph et
il est en apprentissage dans une
boulangerie de sacs né en côte d'or
baghai rodolfo j
c'est dur d'avoir un temps en 2001 c'est
tout
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle joseph dromard j'ai
22 ans je suis apprenti boulanger un
brevet de maîtrise je travaille dans une
boulangerie à sac né en côte d'or
tu peux mettre josette selon nous tue
pour un acte raté à 65 % si tu veux un
et tu mettras 20 grammes de sel au kilo
sites opel pour le vertdure
je suis en train de pétrir la pâte à
pain pour la fourmi du lendemain avec du
levain du cdh de la farine de l'eau
froide a signé on veut pas signer un mix
[Musique]
j'ai commencé par un crp de boulanger
puis j'ai voulu poursuivre mon
apprentissage dans différentes
boulangeries
afin de perfectionner dans mon travail
aujourd'hui je fais 2 à brevet de
maîtrise dans cette boulangerie ou où je
me plais énormément pour moi être
artisan boulanger c'est pouvoir créer
quelque chose à partir de deux plus de
choses finalement on aime beaucoup les
métiers alimentaires puisque je suis
assez gourmand vie jamais mangé il ya
tout cet aspect là de créativité et de
création je pense que j'ai beaucoup
d'imagination et puis j'aime bien
j'ai même écrit une nouvelle chose faire
de nouveaux produits
donc cela on va les faire
en bâtard
donc pas trop serré
c'est un jeune qui est passionné donc
quand on est passionné ben c'est facile
les gains qui est ponctuelle qui a envie
de découvrir il a la même envie de faire
du chocolat il veut faire la ville masri
voulu faire comprendre que chaque chose
demande du temps et donc il faut juste
le retenir c'est comme un cheval
fougueux il faut pouvoir tirer sur les
rênes pour pas qu'ils puissent trop trop
s'envoler dans tout ce qui fait j'ai
toujours voulu faire depuis mon c'est
râpé un pain qui se rapprocher
soit le meilleur pour la santé des gens
possible les pics les un goût assez
spécifique d'où mon envie de pouvoir
travailler des farines issues de
variétés anciennes de blé ce qui est
très intéressant ici c'est qu'on a on a
la ferme qu'à 2 à moins de deux
kilomètres on travaille en circuit court
et ça permet d'avoir une relation
directe avec
le meunier l'agriculteur
comprend mieux notre matière première
donc c'est très intéressant pour
comprendre
la suite d'une fabrication
je crois pour moi la boulangerie les
champs du destin là vous me trouve ça un
peu comme une famille
car on est tous ensemble et puis on
j'aimerais complicité avec six mois puis
zut
c'est une vraie joie de travailler avec
lui
et pouvoir progresser ensemble car lui
aussi est un apprentissage et puis
pouvoir produire
de belles choses arrivé en même temps
dans la boulangerie donc là début
septembre et on vient tous les deux de
franche-comté donc des fois on est un
peu des pics là-dessus ce qu on est un
peu chauvin
donc oui ils nous font un peu des
blagues sur le compte et surtout ça a
payé mais non sinon pas c'est quelqu'un
d'assez réservé joseph il parle pas
beaucoup
or là ce que je fais on appelle ça la
signature du boulanger ça va permettre
de favoriser le développement du pain
alors de la cuisson est ainsi aussi
apporté une valeur esthétique au pas
j'aime beaucoup ces dernières étapes de
fabrication car ça permet de voir la
finalité de notre travail j'aime bien de
sortir après du tout pour sentir mandat
pour regarder s'il est bien sûr
ici je suis très éloigné de ma région
après cela deux heures de film par an
alors lance tout mon jeu quand le
week-end parce que j'ai la chance
d'avoir mis en ligne dans cette
boulangerie alors j'aime bien faire les
week-ends nous avions entre amis ou ma
famille tout simplement ce soit des
brioches des burgers des pizzas
maintenant j'espère j'espère pouvoir
avoir ma propre boulangerie même si je
montre beaucoup de confiance en moi mais
j'espère il y avait
[Musique]